kansas city chiefs in red again
for the second straight year how can
that be here's how it'd be
the tampa bay buccaneers the home team
literally and
via the rotation that happens odd years
the nfc's the home team even years the
afc's the home team they get to pick the
jersey
the buccaneers have chosen white so the
kansas city chiefs boy and that's a good
looking red jersey it is the super bowl
55 patch on it but apparently
it comes down to something as simple as
tom brady
is four in one when wearing
a white jersey in the super bowl
so that's why they're wearing that i
mean that's that's the stands that's
that's what we know is it's really just
come down to that
i mean uh which which you know i want to
go like well they are 1-0 and super
bowls they were actually in the
buccaneers in a red jersey
um the other thing i thought of is i
guess what also you probably think about
the match up
earlier this season right and the bucks
were probably wearing red on that game i
didn't look it up but maybe we could
figure that out here as
in a second i'll check on my own
computer but
but i would think that probably plays
into it too wait we want we want we lost
in the red jerseys at home
let's change it up and wear the white
ones this time see if it brings a little
bit better luck to us
i mean that's the way coaches think and
i'm sure the brady thing is a factor in
this too
also also they've been on the road
the entirety sure of the right
postseason now
now washington i believe was white on
white yeah for that game in the wild
card round so the bucks didn't wear
white then
but i remember two other instances
beyond brady
because the patriots in super bowl 52
were the home team they chose to wear
white because of this whole brady and
white
dynamic super bowl 50
the broncos who had lost when they'd
worn dark
one when they wore white they wore or
especially for elway
elway was unlucky in dark and lucky and
white elway went with the white jersey
they had the choice they wore white in
super bowl 50 and they won
and in super bowl 40 the steelers as the
afc representative were the home team
they chose to wear white because they
had gotten there the hard way the three
wins on the road
and three wins in their white jerseys so
i you know what if that's the case with
brady why don't they just
wear white all the time at home all the
time right
just choose to wear white i think they
wore white and in tampa usually
they do wear white early on in the year
because it can be so hot down there
to where you make the other team wear
the dark jerseys
uh that is something that goes on but
yeah i i hear you
uh but that's that's cool it's a little
change up
i'm excited for that i'm always excited
to see the jerseys for the super bowl
and veal
unveiled you know the field itself those
are things i'm excited for right now
what's the field look like with the new
paint job
and the perfect grass and all those type
of things and
uh yeah i think we could see a real
exciting game for sure
and as it relates to superstitions
regarding uniforms
pete has found the answer to why the
steelers
have only one helmet decal
on their head gear when the team
introduced a new design they had gold
helmets
actually they were yellow i've got one
downstairs one little mini ones i kind
of
i hate them and i like them that yellow
helmet there it is there's the head oh
god
so ugly it looks good they they didn't
know how it would look
they put the decal on one side for a
test run
and in 1962 they finished nine and five
qualified for the playoffs it was their
best season in franchise history they've
been around 30 years at that point
and then what they did for their first
ever playoff game
they switched the helmet to black it's
stayed black ever since but they stayed
with the
one decal because they thought the one
decal
was lucky in some way i like it they
never went to two decals
because of that so now we know and it's
amazing i mean i've
lived in and around pittsburgh my entire
life and i never knew that so thank you
pete yeah thank you so much more for
that
than the jj watts stuff from last
segment
so what what do you think the biggest
home field advantage is for the
buccaneers this week given that they're
not going to have a full stadium and who
knows maybe the chiefs fans would have
overrun the stadium just like they
overran the one
farther south in florida last year right
i would have bet on that i would have i
i thought
you know that was something i was
thinking of like just because you're the
home team as you as we both know
super bowl is up for grabs it has
nothing to do with
you know you know where where the team's
at
or nobody gets extra tickets it's
usually a very
corporate crowd and then okay do those
fan bases want to come in
and buy you know tickets off a stub hub
and do all those type of things and try
to dominate
you know the stadium that way i i i
would say
out of the two things i think are the
three things you mentioned the locker
room maybe
that's probably where i'd look at it and
just being in your own stadium
i think that's an advantage the friendly
con finds you your own stadium
you know as a quarterback and as a
football player you know every stadium
on the
every field and stadium has a different
look and feel
and the sight lines are different that's
one thing for a quarterback that's that
is important you can get to a stadium
you know one week where let's say it's
jerry's world and it's
big and vast and you know the stands are
you know wide open in some spots behind
that
and you could feel like man this this
field feels gigantic this feels huge
and then you can go up the land ball
field and everything's so tight and
close where you could be like
i think i could throw this 100 yards on
this is this 100 yard field you you it
it almost feels smaller that way so
things like that do play into their
advantage
too just feeling comfortable oh the
sun's here the sun's there
the lights of the stadium that probably
to me is the biggest advantage that the
bucks have even over the locker room
does it become a factor at all that it's
jarring that it's different like it
looks so
unusual in comparison to the normal home
game well
whether it's approaching the stadium
with the concrete barriers and the
perimeter
and just everything feels different you
get inside the stadium
it feels different there's different
banners there's different signs there's
like you said it's just yeah it does it
does it put you off at all do you think
because yeah we're in our stadium but
this looks nothing like our stadium
usually looks well i
i i i listen i haven't played in many
super bowls all right so i can't speak
to that i could speak to
one experience in my life that i had
like that a home playoff game in tampa
where okay the stadium was definitely
decorated a little different
everybody had like you know buccaneer
flags and they were
so you knew it was a different day and
there was a different energy
but i i don't i don't think it's any
different than you know
you know coming home every day and then
all of a sudden you come home on a day
where
your your wife and your whatever your
family's gonna throw a big party
and you go oh okay it's just spruced up
a little bit i'm still home
but it's a little different today i
don't think it's gonna affect the play
is what i'm saying i think it actually
will probably excite them to be like
man look at our stadium it looks really
cool this feels big time
and it'll add to the energy of the game
we need to get points bet
to generate odds on one of the two
quarterbacks throwing the football
into the hole one of the cannons in the
ship
hey you might be mahomes and brady but
you ain't chris sims throwing to the
buccaneer ship
pete's gonna act uh ask let's call it
the chris sims memorial
cannon shot right let's do that yeah
right
yes all right they can reach it that's
for sure i'm surprised more people
don't do it to where you score in that
end zone those two i mean mahomes he
could probably throw it over the pirate
ship and out of the stadium
right but it's arm strength is one thing
accuracy is the other
i i i don't know i i would say brady but
some of those passes last week well as
long as nobody's about to hit him he'll
have a chance
to put it accurately i'm sorry i'm
trying to i'm trying to compensate for
the fact that no one else other than us
will say that tom brady wasn't very good
on sunday in the second half first half
great second half not but uh yeah got to
put it in the hole
in the cannon to complete the chris sims
memorial cannon shot
um all right scottie miller was on with
dan patrick yesterday
and he he he said something interesting
so let's
let's uh defer to dp and scotty miller
and we'll react on the other side
how how would you do if you and tyreek
hill
lined up oh i'm taking me every day of
the week um
i'll take me over anybody tyreek is
unbelievable
uh super quick unbelievable talent but
we're talking about race i mean i got
all the confidence myself against going
up against anybody
that's a interesting take man you gotta
have confidence in yourself though i'll
give them that
okay but uh tyrique has already
commented by the way he said good for
him
how motivating is this for you patrick
and the chiefs
yeah i mean i think you're more
motivating uh on yourself than
being in the super bowl if you're not
ready to play for the super bowl i don't
think you uh
you're gonna get ready so uh uh he is a
fast dude he's a great great receiver
um but uh i like my like my guy
look i i love bulletin board material
because i love to hear all the people
say that that stuff doesn't matter when
in fact it does matter
i don't think scottie miller saying i
could beat tyree kill in a race
change is a damn thing for anyone it's
not going to make tyree kill run
any faster gee tyrique if you just tried
a little harder maybe you'd be even
faster than you are no right
all it means is scottie miller you know
he said something that will never be
unproven well are they going to race i
i'd pay
for it i'd go 5.99 maybe 9.99
for a paper it's been unproven it's
already been
unproven until he can run a slant route
like i saw
last week or one of these punt returns
or one of these speed sweeps
where he weaves around the field and
everybody else looks like they're an
amateur
then i'll start having a real
conversation about whoa scotty miller
might be
he's fast don't get me wrong we're not
we're not talking about a race through
an obstacle course we're talking about
straight line speed
difference between straight line speed
and all of the weaving and the
suddenness and the acceleration sure
guys around sure like they're like
they're on ice skating
yup i don't give a damn what kind of
race it is weaving straight ahead
you know running with one leg i'm taking
tyrique
all day and you're right it's not going
to matter with anything in the game
but like it might energize him during
the game like the first time he breaks
down the
buccaneer sidelines for a 60-yard
touchdown he'll probably be shooting the
deuce to scotty miller or saying
something to him it'll be more something
like that
than anything but you're right it's not
true bulletin board material
the only way miller would have a chance
short of food poisoning or
some other foul play would be like a
tortoise in the hair type of a thing
where tyreek hill is so overconfident he
just
he just doesn't take it seriously and
right at the finish line here comes
scotty miller that's
we we know too many all-time
football all-time football people right
you and i we've had this
rodney harrison tony dungy other people
and i mean coach dungey has commented
before that tyrique is
definitely one of the two or three
fastest guys he's ever seen in his life
he's been around a long time on a lot of
good teams
and a lot of good football players and i
think that kind of puts it in
perspective
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports